because the last time uh you guys were
on the show together and and anthony and
gregory did a boxing challenge and in a
bit of a shock result anthony won
is it weird
a heavyweight champion of the world
would beat a biscuit-eating comedian
he should have both his arms tied behind
his back
now so this time this time we've got
another challenge with the last time it
was you know those boxing things and you
hit the box in there so that's what we
did the last time this time we've gone
for one of those fun fair uh test of
strength machines okay okay so if you'd
like to bring in uh the machine here it
is
[Music]
come down now to our our test of
strength now the two of you are going to
celebrate you're gonna have a bit of a
face-off in front of it okay okay we're
taking this seriously no no yeah we're
taking it seriously and it's not it's it
is of strength but i believe technique
plays a huge part in that's all right so
how about oh look oh
oh
it's taller
we're taller yeah
okay okay and uh now maybe i'll be
turning up to get us in the mood
you got to see the mood uh ken brown is
going to give us uh just a little bit of
form before we do this okay you do your
face off do your face off come on come
on okay off you go okay ladies and
gentlemen on the left
they
call him the postman because he always
delivers it's the undisputed heavyweight
champion of the world anthony joshua
[Applause]
how's he looking
because he sometimes delivers
unless he gets stuck in traffic
it is greg man mountain david
so
here we go here we go so aj yes you go
first ah well that's almost heavy i
thought that was gonna be heavier okay
okay
okay you go first
mind the cameras here we go
it's all golf
whoa oh dear
thank you
[Applause]
hit the bell hit the bell hit the bell
come on
[Applause]
walk this way
walk this way this way okay here we go
anthony why don't you help judy
yes you know maybe greg can help you
yeah
yeah okay here we go here we go are you
doing tonight just handed a hammer to
damn judy dench
[Applause]
okay here we go here we go here we go
okay sorry yeah
[Applause]
yes look at you 50 shades darker but
actually this isn't darker it's more
romantic i would say yeah i think that's
probably true yeah um
uh yes but there's probably more sex in
it
which
more sex
jamie doesn't speak
i mean i make noises
american accented noises
do they let you do that i mean like when
you're when you're doing the scenes does
the director say
more vocalization
um
no one comes like that
[Applause]
[Laughter]
there's some scenes where
they will play music maybe a bit of if
it's a wide shot and it's not like
so
it's the closest we get to sort of kind
of sort of just sort of going forward in
one piece and they'll play music or
something and my temptation is always
just to try to make the cuddle laugh so
sometimes
i'll do things like when there's a
moment where i'm meant to you know
orgasm i'll be like
[Laughter]
it's like a ryanair flight when a
ryanair flight lands
[Applause]
what do you mean if i can
said mary poppins
dosha sally expiaistic fragilis
[Applause]
jonah what was the what's that i cuz
i've never i'm pretty thick but i've
never understood the thing that morgan
freeman
said to you that
oh so when i was this was about 10 years
ago
i did a film with morgan freeman it was
a really small film and the first 10
pages or 10 minutes of the film are us
two just driving together in a car
and talking and it took three days to
shoot and uh he didn't talk to me the
entire time like in between takes right
because he had so much dialogue i
learned later right okay so he was just
you know so in between we wouldn't
really chat and but we were in the car
together for three days and then at the
end of the third day
he just turns to me and he goes jonah
jonah babona banana fana fufona me ma
momona
jona
that's it and it was like super
uncomfortable i didn't know what to say
it was one of the more weird moments of
my life
and i just didn't know what to say so i
just said thank you
and then he said it was quiet again and
he said
do me
like what he's like
do my name
and i was like do your name and he's
like yeah do my name and i was like
morgan morgan boborgan
me my mo morgan
morgan
he went all right and then we never
spoke again
the only thing that links our guys
everyone started very young now ben the
last time you're here
we enjoyed very much uh your early work
on the voyage of the mimi yes we're not
going to show any more thank you do
google it because it is worth seeing
look at that slide
what's he got cooking
no seriously you really need to google
it
that's you started was it modeling you
started you were quite young when you
started modeling i was just sure and so
i no i mean yes but not like proper
like that either
yeah
[Applause]
and then emma you did some extraordinary
work as a child actor
i mean take this meryl streep oh look at
that
what is that that is genius is that
prosthetics that's a nice princess and
the p
i did a kind of edgar j robinson thing
where i was like
[Laughter]
it's gene
ever tonight with la la land in mind we
are going to focus on the early dancing
career of mr ryan gosling
now make sense of the only video you
have tonight is yeah yeah
so the dance troupe you were in can you
tell us about because apparently
young dancers they can be quite vicious
it's a cut-throat business
and i had to get out
i was on some
kind of uh canadian star search and uh i
somehow made it to the finals and uh my
main competition were these two
uh twins who were tap dancers and they
were dancing to phil collins uh two
hearts
and they had big heart-shaped bows and
they were just
they were the ones to beat so
i remember uh you know wishing them luck
and going on stage and i was getting
ready to start was dancing the everybody
dance now by cnc music factory of course
yeah and i'm getting ready to start
which is this is how you started a
winning dance number if you want to know
get out of your hand tonight
and i look up into the into the uh just
off stage and the two twins are standing
there like the
twins from the shining
and they're just going like this
[Applause]
i just shimmied my way all the way to
to that trophy to that tiny little
trophy
because i i was going is this the same
dream i was going to say it's all it's
an all-girl troupe but obviously it's
not you're in it right but but
you are the only boy in it yeah that was
the was that the that was the point that
was the gimmick they let me dance there
for free because i was a guy because if
you
had a guy you you would win
oh okay yeah so are you ready to see the
the
dance stylist
uh i believe you're dancing to kathy
dennis's classic touch me
um uh did the troupe have a name ryan
it was elite dance studio
uh how old are you in this one
old enough to know better
enjoy
[Music]
[Applause]
hey
i wish i could say someone said here you
have to wear this
but that was my idea i thought i have a
vision for this number
and silver hammer pants
they are br the silver hammer plants are
i don't think we know we gave them
enough of a shot we gave up with hammer
but i don't i think we should we should
have kept them going now
[Music]
you